wieder haben sich umweltaktivisten auf
straßen festgeklebt und damit den
verkehr lahmgelegt natürlich müssen
umweltaktionen sichtbar sein damit sie
bemerkt werden tausende unbeteiligte zu
geiseln dieser aktion zu machen kommt
allerdings nicht gut an und ist auch
gefährlich wie sich heute zeigt
mensch gegen maschine
der kampf geht in die nächste runde
radikale klimaschützer blockieren
autofahrer in berlin an der
stadtautobahn acht uhr morgens mitten im
morgendlichen berufsverkehr
da wo berlin am besten gelaunt ist
schiebt ein autofahrer eine klima
demonstranten gezielt ich von der straße
sie liegt auf der motorhaube nötigung
der mercedes fahrer fährt einfach los
lässt sich nicht behindern
dieses video hat die gruppe last
generation auf twitter gepostet die
straßen blockieren sehen sich im recht
ich mache das weil der fossile wahnsinn
endlich aufhören muss weil nicht mehr
gebohrt werden darf wenn wir schon in
grimma notstand stecken es ist die
nächste runde der klima blockaden in der
hauptstadt die klima kleber kleben
wieder schon am montag haben sich
radikale klimaschützer auf 4 befahrenen
straßen in berlin festgeklebt 180
polizisten waren im einsatz
28 strafverfahren wegen nötigung und
widerstand gegen die staatsgewalt wenn
ich wieder herauskommen werde ich mich
wieder an die straße kriegen einfach
weil nichts mehr zu verlieren habe wir
sind die letzte generation die noch
etwas ändern kann anna klimakatastrophe
die straßen blockieren wollen druck auf
die regierung ausüben geplant seien
tägliche unterbrechungen des
straßenverkehrs in berlin bis scholz
glaubhaft erklären dass es keine
ölbohrungen in der nordsee geben werde
das heißt für hunderttausende autofahrer
in berlin viel geduld mitbringen
doch schon jetzt bei hält nicht jeder
einen kühlen kopf